Tradutor: Esther Duraes
Revisor: Custodio Marcelino
Salve força dos ventos, Êparrei Oyá!
Eu peço licença pra entrar.
Salve mãe rainha, Odoyá!
Força das águas de Oxum pra purificar,
eu peço licença pra entrar.
Salve, salve, guerreiras amazonas!
Eu peço licença pra entrar.
Força indígena milenar,
eu peço licença pra entrar.
Quem veio antes de mim e quem ainda virá,
Oi.
Moça, a gente pode conversar?
Eu não quero tomar muito do seu tempo,
eu só queria falar algumas coisinhas.
Eu preciso pedir uma pausa
no meio da sua rotina.
Eu sei da sua correria.
É a vida, a família, a casa, cria,
comida e ainda nem deu meio-dia.
Você sabia que daqui eu escuto
seus pensamentos em guerra?
É, eu também batalho
comigo mesma todos os dias.
E até hoje eu não sei dizer
muito bem como fica esse placar.
Eu quero te fazer uma pergunta:
"Quantas vezes você realmente se escuta?
E quantas dessas obedece o seu pensar?"
Quando a noite cai
e a mente trabalha em silêncio,
meu corpo, por vezes, me diz: "Vai!"
Mas reflito sobre tudo o que penso.
Nem sempre o impulso é seguro,
nem sempre traz acalento.
E, por vezes, peço: "Pai,
livrai-me do que eu não sustento!"
Eu já pensei e dispensei sem me escutar.
Eu já pensei e repensei após refletir.
Eu já ignorei sinais
que vieram pra me livrar.
Eu demorei pra aprender a me ouvir.
Você sabia que existe uma força
dentro de todas nós?
Uma herança que nos acompanha
desde as nossas ancestrais?
Só é preciso estar atenta aos sinais.
Eu sei que existe um abismo
entre a sua razão e a emoção.
E não nos ensinaram
muito bem como trabalhar isso.
Afinal, há milênios querem
domesticar os nossos instintos.
E é por isso que eu
insisto em te perguntar:
"Quantas vezes você realmente se escuta?
E quantas dessas obedece o seu pensar?"
As responsabilidades
de uma mulher moderna
impedem que ela tenha
tempo de se questionar.
E, enquanto cuidamos
de tudo ao nosso redor,
esquecemos simplesmente de nos cuidar.
Quando compreendi
o que dentro de mim pulsava,
entendi que eu sou a guia
da minha própria jornada.
Daí fui perceber o quanto me flagelava
buscando a minha autodestruição,
pelo simples fato
de não seguir a minha intuição.
Intuição: substantivo feminino,
ato de perceber, discernir
ou até mesmo pressentir coisas
independentemente de raciocínio.
É resgatar sensações que foram extintas.
Entender que tudo é
uma questão de sintonia.
Ser sensível em meio ao caos
é andar na contramão.
E não se culpe por nem sempre
conseguir, tudo bem!
Ninguém disse que seria fácil existir.
Apenas não crie barreiras
em torno de si mesma,
busque sua força interna pra reagir.
Eu escrevo pra expurgar os medos,
pra afastar a solidão
em meio a tantos enredos,
despertar o que me habita,
desvendar meus próprios segredos.
Eu pedia desculpa toda vez
depois de falar, como se fosse um erro,
um defeito de nascença querer me colocar.
Ambientes tão hostis nos tornam
prisioneiras de nossas próprias ideias.
Mas revoluções, revoluções sempre foram
feitas a partir de distintos ideais.
Seja o seu próprio néctar,
explore esse multiverso mulher,
rejeite o que te afeta,
respeite o seu tempo,
perceba esse florescer.
E não se preocupe
quando precisar desaguar,
é normal transbordar.
Entenda, nós mulheres
temos pacto com o mar.
E as lágrimas,
as lágrimas são a hemodiálise da alma.
Escute essa voz interna
que tenta se comunicar.
Não negue suas intuições, confie nelas!
De bruxas e sábias, todas temos um pouco.
O quanto disso você consegue resgatar?
A minha intenção hoje
aqui é fazer você refletir,
olhar pra dentro de si,
pro seu momento presente,
pro que o seu corpo sente,
e como ele tenta se comunicar.
Pra que a partir de agora,
desse momento,
você realmente se escute
e obedeça o seu pensar.
Obrigada.
(Aplausos)